a new york city firefighter as with any
firefighter
in america in the beginning takes the
oath
and says i am willing to give up my life
for someone i don't know to put myself
in a dangerous position
to save the life of someone i don't know
sometimes you are called upon to fulfill
that
and that's true for firefighters and
police officers and military
throughout america
being in new york city being in the
bronx or harlem or
um some parts of brooklyn or southern
queens
uh
you you need to be ready to get your ass
kicked
there's so many variables i feel like
like you have the worst crime in the
country
now now they do i mean
they're in some trouble in new york now
i mean especially police the firemen get
a little bit of a break
um but the f the firemen are also a
target of
being the man you know and getting a
false alarm
called in and they call it airmail where
you drop a
a bucket off the roof of the building
you call in a false alarm
the cops get there the firemen gets
there you have a bucket of
cement and you drop it off and try and
kill them
you know that's come back that used to
be in the 60s and 70s and early 80s
uh and that went away but now that's
back again
um so not only are you going in a
neighborhood trying to help innocent
people
but you they're trying to kill you know
the bad people in that neighborhood are
also trying to kill you
and you know they'll take pot shots and
stuff at a fire truck going down the
street or
a police car you know they have these
now in the police cars
next to where you sit on the window they
have these little bulletproof pieces of
glass so the cop can sit back
and hide behind the glass so somebody
can't take a pot shot at them
um in these smaller cities now
they're also their economies are trouble
in trouble
and their fire departments are very busy
like we used to be in the 80s 70s in the
bronx
so a a firefighter a new york city
firefighter friend of mine his son is
now a baltimore fireman
they get their asses kicked by fires
every time they come in and all these
smaller cities are like that
the the bridgeports chicago's detroit's
um
all over america um
they're they're they they know what it's
like to be a new york city fireman
because they're getting their asses
kicked and and they're in danger
his son already he's only two two years
on the job
and he already rescued somebody from a
fire you know
young guy early twenties wow um
so i i wouldn't the new york city
fireman thing new york city is the
biggest
it's the busiest you know all that stuff
but you have this the vertical aspect
i mean you're fighting fire so now and
they keep building bigger
they keep building them taller i would
look
if you're a billionaire or a
multi-millionaire good for you
don't live on 125th floor it's a bad
idea
we can't get to you you know we can't
get to you
they they've created in the new york
city fire department they've created a
new signal
for like an ultra high rise really yeah
we do high-rise fires every day in new
york every day what is what is a high
rise considered
how does that how fast exactly i would
say um
up to 60 or 70 stories okay
and then and then what we call the super
talls are the ones that are
tall i'm not sure what the numbers might
be 75 and taller
okay but the problem is
our response time if the fire is up top
yeah
our time to get there is doubled because
we have to get up there inside the
building
right you know and so that fire is going
to get even worse
and if you're trapped we're not going to
get to you very quickly you know
um so these super calls are are a
problem
for for us and they're a problem for the
people that live there or
their offices are there they're a
problem for them
if you're i mean i'm coming at this from
a completely ignorant
standpoint but if you're on like say the
hundredth floor
of a high-rise and there's a fire in
your building what do you do
i'm sorry if you're on the 100th floor
and there's a fire in your
penthouse or whatever it is and it's on
your level
what are you supposed to do get down get
down just go down
get down because the fire only burns up
don't take an elevator
just get below get below the fire smoke
heat all that goes up
get below the fire and and then if
you're there get out of the building
even if you have to go down 100 floors
in the stairwell go down
yeah get out don't take the elevator
elevators are a very bad idea in a high
rise fire
the uh elevators can behave erratically
they could
you push to go down it could go up and
the doors could open to the fire
it's unpredictable so do the stairwell
thing
uh get down below if you physically
can't
get a few floors below and call for help
and we'll come get you
uh smoke detectors the most important
thing
yeah working smoke detector it gives you
a fighting chance to get out
before it gets bad i can't imagine
i can't imagine having a job like that i
mean it's just a completely
different world it's the greatest job in
the world
the greatest the most satisfying the
most
heroic um the most fun
you know because you're working with a
group of people who
[Music]
you count on every second for your life
and you live together in a firehouse you
eat together you sleep together you cook
together
you you risk your lives together you
know their families they know your
family
you know that if i die that guy's taking
care of my kids
forever which is what i continue to do
now for my friends
children you know i told you the story
of young mike lynch who now wants to go
in the military
he was two years old when his father the
angel
was murdered and i promised
a young mike's mom
mike senior's widow denise that i would
take care of his children
and now i am mentoring his son he's 22
years old
he's going to go in we hope to the navy
seals we're trying to get him there
and he's like a son to me and any one of
them
if i was killed on 9 11 any if i had
kids
any one of them would have done that for
me and
that's why being a new york city
firefighter being a firefighter
anywhere in america is the greatest job
in the world
it's family you don't you don't get rich
right but you can pay your bills
and and you grow up doing something very
important
you're you teach your children about
about what's important in life
the most important things and
and you have a blast along the way
you